there's a massive weight we all feel
because we can feel that our country is
coming apart due to cruelty and
inhumanity and despair and the despair
unfortunately is going to be with us
until we can somehow restore most of the
40 million jobs that have been lost give
people a sense of the future I hope our
podcast can do that and so you know we
had a tough decision as to whether we
were going to focus solely on George
Floyd and Derek Chavan and what happened
in Minneapolis and is now happening
around the country or to talk about our
vision for the future that hopefully can
help address some of these issues we
think that people come to us in part for
a sense of optimism and possibility and
to get away a little bit from a
depressing reality so we're going to
talk about some of the things that
hopefully we can make real in the future
that can help improve our lives and
hopefully make us the kind of country
that is coming together instead of
coming apart I will say just as an
American as a person I'm heartbroken
watching this and I was talking to our
buddy Jermaine Johnson down South
Carolina and he said he cried his eyes
out all day yesterday which was Thursday
the 28th and so this podcast is gonna be
hopefully of lifting and lighthearted
and that's that's intentional in this
very dark time and but I want you to
know if you're American you're hurting
right now we are too and we feel you we
love you and we're gonna fight to fix
this and I hope you guys join us
[Music]
really excited this week to sit down
with Anthony Sierra Moochie to talk
about how we're going to repair the
economy and that's gonna be the theme of
this week is what we can do to try and
help get people back on their feet so I
tweeted this earlier this week we could
use the citizenship portal where we can
access benefits see tax info renew
licenses connect a bank account fill out
a census register to vote get updates
its 2020 right now this would be
indispensable and eases pandemic for
millions now this got tens of thousands
of likes and retweets because it seems
so obvious when you see it and I thought
of this one because a friend pinged me
with the idea and you know have smart
friends who send good ideas so thank you
for that Eric but also I was literally
just in the process of filling out my
census and and I also know like needed
to figure out my absentee ballot and
they're like these different
interactions you have with the
government and then you're like why is
this such a mess why is this such a
weird patchwork where you know the most
direct thing was trying to get people a
stimulus check of $1,200 like the best
way to do that was through the IRS
through people's bank accounts and tax
records but millions of Americans don't
have tax records like they didn't file
taxes because they're like a cleaning
lady or like a food truck person who's
like just you know doing things on cash
or whatnot and does that person not
deserve the $1,200 like in my mind they
find me the $1,200 worse than anyone
because no they did file taxes because
they're poor so like so to me it's like
the obvious gap is that if there was
like a citizen US where you could just
get your info get your refund fill out
census documents register to vote update
your license but most of us are at least
also speak for myself like I am very
very nervous when I
have to interact with the government
because I'm afraid I'm gonna get dragged
into some bureaucratic hell now
sometimes you know it's easy and you're
like oh that wasn't bad I like paid the
parking ticket and it took me five
minutes but other times you do get
caught in hell like let's call it
renewing a passport or something and
you're like oh no like I have to do what
like yeah you know I remember and this
was a number of years ago but like I
went to Philadelphia to like try and
expedite a passport because for whatever
reason like the office there could
accommodate me in a way that New York's
offices could not and it struck me as I
was like is this really dumb or is just
me it's like why am i why am i taking a
day out of my life to do this so this
would make our government user-friendly
and one of the things I think is really
important is that people don't trust
government for a number of reasons but
they don't trust government for a number
of reasons that I actually really
sympathize with number one is it seems
how to touch an inefficient and there's
like a low degree of user friendliness
or accountability and so if you had a
citizen portal where you interacted with
it you were like oh that was a breeze
and instead of having like that nerd
sense of anxiety that I have when it's
time to do something with the government
you were like whatever like do you get
anxious when you go to your online bank
account or you're like Gmail account
it's like I mean as long as you're not
expecting some like you know terrible
quite like you know financial dreading
but like you're generally fine with the
experience but if I were to go to like a
government website I I would have that
sense of dread like if you can get rid
of that sense of dread that would
actually be a great leap forward for our
confidence in government and oh by the
way it would actually work better to
like in in pandemic if you wanted a
twelve hundred dollars into our hands
you wouldn't necessarily need to rely
upon our tax info maybe it's just like
hey like all you like everyone has the
in portal so just go to the citizen
portal and then you can identify means
of payment like we can venmo it to you
we can PayPal to you one of the things
that strikes me is so ridiculous is
thanks to many people who donated
literally like tens of thousands of
people but most prominently Jack Dorsey
donating five million dollars we have
been sending money to Americans for the
last number of weeks and how do we do it
it's like well we do it the way you
would do it if you were trying to help
your friend which is via cash app or
PayPal or venmo because that's how most
people send and receive money so why is
it that we relatively brand-new
nonprofit can do something that seems
like way beyond the abilities of our
government like if our government wanted
to get us twelve hundred dollars why
could they not just cash up or venmo or
PayPal US humanity forward figured it
out like why is our government unable to
figure it out and that's like the source
of frustration for many many people that
like a citizen portal could help with my
nonprofit still not received it's PPP
loan and it's mainly because we and I'm
sure it's some bureaucratic Craddock
reason we I mean there's no way we we
don't even know if we filled out the
form right like you think you did yes
for some advice there's no rubric oh
yeah take a black hole to the government
and you're like will this come back to
work yeah you don't know here's the
other thing we just did so we filed so
we started too many forward it's a 501 C
4 non-profit which is not tax deductible
to charity but you don't get a tax
deduction if you want a tax deduction
you need to have a 501 C 3 non-profit so
we're creating a 501 C 3 it's not
political please separate from there
Andrews not on the board not related any
political candidate but in order to do
this you have to file the paperwork and
I've literally what do you do you Google
when you can talk to a lawyer have them
do this for you but you Google like how
do you file for a 501 C 3 status and you
end up in this like the depths of a
government website following basically a
long text thread like a almost like a
word document on the web page and you
end up ask yourself is this is this
right is this like is this the right way
to do this
you know there's no and that Damis where
the citizen poor will be helpful is just
like the source of truth source of
legitimacy for all things where you have
to touch the freaking government and it
could be designed in a way that makes
you confident because one of the issues
is that if you go to some government
websites it seems like they were
designed in the 90s and that there are
some some agencies that are using
ancient ancient software and operating
systems like you hear these nightmares
about how you if you go to IRS or some
other agencies they'll be like on
Windows 98 or whatever which like which
I you know I'm not like you know I I
just want to get the job done so if it's
working for you it's fine but like that
you know but like it is tough when
you're not sure whether you're getting
the right info because like that this
thing seems so clunky you know the other
part is the opaqueness where like if you
send a FedEx package you get a tracking
number then you can see what's going on
you know you file like a PPP application
for your nonprofit like do you know
what's going on do you know what the
right time frame is do you know like how
to follow up can you track it do you
know where it is in their process it's
like no it's like send and pray so it's
like our government needs to have like a
higher degree of ability to inspire
confidence and you know and that's that
can be something as basic as and you and
I talked about this act it's like you
start your nonprofit and then no one
signs up and then you just like pretty
up the website and then all of a sudden
everyone's side job like made the same
experience where it's like I started a
non-profit and then no one took it
seriously well I mean whatever like like
I was investing the website but like
when the website got upgraded then all
of a sudden everyone thought it was like
awesome they must be legit yeah so so
yeah this is something that would make
us trust government more and hopefully
it could work better so happily people
got so excited about this idea for a
citizen portal that now we have some
people working on it
there are folks from the humanity
forward community who have volunteered
literally like five hundred people
volunteered to how
and folks are now trying to come up with
what it would look like so if you want
to help out with that you can find the
Twitter thread there's a mini web forum
but we're gonna work on it because
that's the humanity forward way it's
like not enough to [ __ ] about something
and be like oh that sucks like I mean
like we can make it better if you want
to renew your passport
I did this four years ago if you want to
renew your passport listen to this you
have to unless this is change the past
four years so I'll hold me this but this
is all you had to do you had to mail
your existing passport in you had to put
it in the mail and send it to the
government and then three weeks later
you'd get it back and to me that was
terrifying there's like oh you know the
last thing I need is my passport lost in
the mail cuz then what and now you get a
new one - so the whole note that I gotta
find a birth certificate then I add you
all these things so but that said the
government is not terrible at certain
things like the DMV in New York is
seamless fantastic fan-freakin'-tastic I
was in and out in 20 minutes and there
was a whole bunch of thing to have in
that 20 minute so I I do think this is
important will highlight the good stuff
that government is doing yeah there
there so there are certain interactions
where you come away and you're like oh
like that that was painless and like
delightful you know we just need more of
that yeah and so and that I think that
it's almost like there's a lot of good
work that happens in the government in
ways and they don't do himself any
favors by making it so difficult to find
or it's not clear or god knows what
so anyway that was citizen portal this
week the other thing you tweeted about
this Andrew so you talked about the need
for a four-day workweek or someone like
to say a three-day weekend yes I did the
math of those works so I was I looked
into this and I think you know this like
I was looking in the history of weekends
and really it started I mean there's
been they've been around for a while but
it really was a union thing right like
the unions demanded like hey we get two
days off like that's the move and it was
in the right after the Great Depression
if I recall yeah yeah it was in the Fair
Labor Standards Act of 1938 40-hour
workweek well first let me let me
explain the thinking
where right now our workweek is getting
longer not shorter and it's having a
disastrous set of effects on millions of
people where we have this mental health
crisis that we talked about last week we
have this worship of work work ISM and
we're sleep-deprived I mean you can name
it there like all these stacked effects
and it's getting worse now
economists like Keynes projected we'd
have a 15 hour work week by now because
we'd be so wealthy and it turns out he
was right about the level of wealth like
it like that line was correct but he
obviously got the number of hours in the
work week very wrong because it's been
getting longer not shorter here in the
US and Barack Obama actually said to me
we should be looking at a shorter work
week because firms aren't going to
employ people in the same way that they
have previously so let's see what
happens if you do implement three-day
weekends four-day workweek the big thing
people say is like well won't you then
just do 20% less work and that's not
really the way it happens in real life
where organizations actually become more
productive in many cases if you shorten
the workweek and if you think about the
way most of us work we have bursts of
productivity and then bursts of relative
like I'm not really doing a whole lot
right now
and those bursts tend to correspond to
when the deadline is but also what our
schedule is like I'll give you an
example the most productive day that
anyone has is the day before they're
going they go on vacation for a while
like like that like that day all of a
sudden is like you know this gets so
much stuff done nobody knows that
feeling - yeah so Samas this just
getting done is done today so your
productivity expands or contracts
depending upon the schedule and that's
why if you have a four-day workweek you
may get the exact same amount done as
you wouldn't a five-day workweek you
last time so let's stipulate that
productivity let's say stays the same
even though studies have shown I'll
actually go up now then then you have a
three-day weekend which ends up
improving your level of rest your mental
health your relationships your time with
family
it actually has even been shown to help
more evenly distribute like domestic
responsibilities so that there are all
of these positive effects and the
negative effects are as far as I can
tell quite absent in the data and here's
the kicker it would help create jobs at
the margins because if you're a firm and
you have a four-day workweek and let's
say you need coverage then you might
have to hire another like you know 20%
of people and then like have them work
different periods of time so and right
now we're in a situation where we need
to create jobs in the worst way where
we're gonna be short tens of millions of
jobs for months so anything we can do
that's going to stimulate hiring is a
win so the the four-day workweek to me
is something that we should be seriously
looking at and the way you make it
happen is the same way you made the two
day work week happen which is you pass a
law saying hey guess what like these are
gonna be the expected work hours like of
course you can have a firm that has
people work different hours but then you
have to accommodate your employees in
like you know additional ways and like
it's you know frankly like the dumb
question is like it's a law and so right
now we the weekend is essentially
structure on the 40-hour workweek you're
not allowed to have a number of workers
and a lot of work more than 40 hours a
week keep it's an hourly worker right
and so you would make overtime after 30
hours or whatever well you know you yeah
I mean you could you could work with the
number of hours you could like there
different ways you could make the
weekend longer I have a feeling though
that it wouldn't take that much
because if you were to pass along this
direction a lot of major companies would
adopt it and then it's going to be very
difficult for some companies to look up
and say like actually we're gonna ignore
that
like when literally their competitor
companies or hiring the same people oh
it's like it and so it's really
interesting if you were an employee like
which company I'm gonna choose you're
gonna choose the one that with the
four-day workweek and so they're gonna
end up with like you know better people
who are gonna have the same level of
productivity and higher containment
levels and better rest you know it's
like one of the signs to me about how
sleep-deprived we are is that when you
have daylight savings time when you lose
an hour of sleep car accidents go up
like literally if like you you have like
one less hour sleep it screws us up
enough where we're actually like you
know like a non-trivial number of us are
gonna like get an accident so it's like
that there's and I'm you know it's fun
to have this conversation right now like
after Memorial Day could because you
know it's like that three-day weekend
I was saying is like it's 50% better
than a two-day weekend you'll come back
you'll come back into the office like
much more ready to go you'll be more
productive from front to back
there are many workers obviously that
like ironing this well it's like so some
people I know are looking at being like
well it doesn't apply to me because like
I'm like you know I've got a job that
medicine yeah well it's like I get paid
hourly so like what are you talking
about so they're there have to be ways
that we make it like a universal basic
income make it so that people are able
to work and not feel like they have to
work themselves to the bone the way that
many many people do right now is there
an argument that economic activity will
be boosted because you have more
weekends like do people spend I don't
have you know those numbers do people
spend more on the weekends I imagine yes
when you have free time that's when you
go out to dinner that's when you're
going on vacation that's when you're
traveling this when you're spending more
gas who knows yeah of course you know of
course we spend more more money on
recreational stuff on weekends then when
you're working like you know all you can
do is you lunch at your desk and whatnot
right it's the Akana
is stimulative yep the but I also think
this I think is it clearly pinched a
nerve on Twitter on you when you tweeted
it out so that's why I wanted to explore
it more with you in this and you talked
about this a lot personally in on the
trail like this the why of like it begs
a question why are we working you know
I'm saying and I think you it's obvious
ACK where we're working to maximize GDP
like having your GDP contribution today
if not then [ __ ] you but you've kind of
argued that work is activity that make
society better theoretically and now oh
I love to work don't get me wrong I've
learned that the hard way man that Ronny
Chang thing we're like Asians don't take
off
they don't stop for Christmas they don't
stop for Thanksgiving like that's yang
man like it's like in all day I love
that you like finish your presidential
run you just kept working
you're insane but the I are we were
joking on our team Andrews the irony of
we're gonna work with the irony is we're
gonna work a seven day workweek to fight
for a four-day work week around the rest
of the country oh yeah that's pretty
good summary man because so so here's
the thing too is like if you have a
four-day work week and you're someone
who likes to work then you know what
you're gonna do you're gonna get tons of
work done during those four days and
then those other three days you're gonna
do different types of work on like
yourself your family your health your
relationships your community like you'll
find stuff to do if you want to work
like nothing's gonna keep you from from
working but you'll get the same amount
of work done in less time yeah I'm a fan
I was on the fence at first it's like
never changing stuff and I think there's
a lot of arguments the Pro column and
not a lot of arguments in the con column
but the here's the money shot Andrew do
you pick Monday or Friday my instinct is
you pick Friday because I don't get [ __ ]
done on Fridays and I'm just kidding
[Laughter]
but you know I mean another thing you do
is you could just like let a company
choose and then you have some companies
in effect Monday and some comes in
effect Friday if you're like a certain
type of business but generally speaking
you'd want to pick the same day for most
companies so that so that everyone would
have the benefits because one of the
things you realize quickly is that
weekends are best when they're
synchronous if you want someone to be
sad you give them time off when no one
else's time off so so so generally
speaking we would just pick Friday's I
think that would be the win
[Music]
I was a very nerdy kid I loved getting
books at those little book clubs that we
had in our schools you know what I don't
know if you all remember what I'm
talking about anyway today what is that
book Club of the 21st century I'm happy
to say that there's a company now
literati that's a godsend for parents
like me who have young kids where you're
trying to find good books for your kids
that are age-appropriate and educational
but you don't have that much time you're
not exactly gonna become an expert in
kids books at least I'm not so what do
we do we subscribe to literati which
then sends you books for your kids is
the number one book club for kids and
here's the kicker if you don't dig the
books you actually can send them back
can you believe that it's nuts
each literati box contains five books
based on a theme and a personalized note
to your child so it seems like someone
actually cares about your child anyway
so if this sounds good to you it's like
a personalized book club for your kids
where they'd use get sent books it makes
you feel like a good parent you can read
that book to your with your child they
can read it on their own if they can
read which my kids one of them can't
and so that's literati what a great
freaking idea it started by some awesome
entrepreneurs I love this thing to death
you're gonna love it too and if you want
to get 25 percent off your first two
orders just go to literati dot-com slash
yang best offer available anywhere go to
literati comm slash yang for 25 percent
off your first two orders that's Li ter
ATI if you don't know how to spell
literati you're literally not literati
if you can't spell literati but it's
literati comm slash yang get some books
for your kids
they will then learn to read and then
eventually make you proud
[Music]
[Applause]
let's talk about the economy a bit and
jobs
you you said something really powerful
that a bunch of news outlets covered in
their own right which I love when that
happens like that makes my job easy I
have to do end up the hound reporters
you said you warned that 42 percent of
lost jobs won't come back
and we're gonna face something two times
a Great Recession permanently and so
let's start with that because you in
Scott Moochie talk about what the hell's
happening with the economy going forward
why won't the jobs come back there's a
host of reasons why let's say 40 to 42
percent of these I mean that's too
precise like like so one estimate I got
was 42 another estimates 40 so you can
say 41 percent for fun so so if you lose
41 percent of 38 million jobs that's 15
million jobs so why are these jobs not
going to come back some of them are are
gone for good because activity in that
industry is going to be lower for the
foreseeable future
so what's that retail hospitality
restaurants travel convention
entertainment sports movies travel
pretty much anything in that zone you're
looking at cutting significant numbers
of jobs for the foreseeable future
Macy's furloughed 130,000 employees how
many of those employers anything and
I'll bring back well it turns out they
had dozens of stories they were
considering closing anyway that were
closed for a while and now we're really
hemorrhaging money and it turns out that
mall foot traffic is down 30% so what
are they gonna do they're gonna get rid
of that store and then they're not gonna
bring those people back so you
extrapolate that through the economy and
you wind up with millions and millions
of jobs that are just gone for good now
the the next cause is that many
companies are trying to use this time to
hasten adjustments that they were
looking
making anyway and those adjustments tend
to cost people jobs so this is
automation in large part you know if you
can get things done with software and
autonomous vehicles then you do it and
then you have fewer people and so you
make those moves now you make those
investments now no the the third thing
is that like a lot of businesses have
abandon any sort of expansion issues or
like like you're looking at just this
massive depressed economic environment
and so people that had job offers have
them disappear like hiring plans have
completely changed if you were running
an operation right now you're taking as
little risk as possible and you're
looking around and saying wait a minute
you know what like that person that I've
kept around uh you know I wasn't sure
that that I was gonna keep them around
anyway so like you know let me does not
bring them back you know it's like if
you have a typical organization but
let's call it like a hundred people you
might have been looking to cut the
bottom 20 anyway and so now is the time
to do that because of the business
climate
so those three forces are going to make
it so that 40 percent of these jobs do
not return secular industry change
automation and acceleration of
investment and accelerating the
unpleasant staffing choices that you are
putting off for a rainy day and now it's
pouring rain so those are some of the
big things that are going to keep many
many Americans on the sidelines and this
to me is the central challenge of this
time is if you look at 15 million plus
jobs gone for good
you're looking at something almost two
times the scale of the Great Recession
which took us years and years to try and
recover from and then you get into the
family where they lost their job let's
call it like the bartender job or the
nail salon or whatever it is there's
like a period of time where that person
can be okay
let's call it two to three months but
then after that time passes things start
to go south in many many ways not just
to their personal financial situation
and savings but in terms of their
attachment to the labor force where
people are a bit like muscles where if
they don't get used for a while they
tend to atrophy and this is evidenced by
people just dropping out of the
workforce right now we have the lowest
labor force participation rate the
lowest percentage of Americans working
right now than in recorded history it's
something like 51% something incredibly
low and that's the disaster because if
you translate that into people just
dropping out of the workforce you wind
up with dysfunction to the roof in that
home in that community over time so we
have to try and hook people back into
the workforce as quickly as possible and
a mammoth scale millions and millions of
jobs this to me is job one like we very
urgently need to try and supercharge the
household that right now is look as
trite as balancing whether they're going
to keep on working and looking for a job
or whether they're gonna drop out my
brother works in private equity and one
of the things that they talk about is
that it's the best time to really
understand your business is during a
recession because the dumb money is out
so like what do you meant by that so in
a recession people are only spending
what they really want so they're gonna
open up their wallet they're spending
for the raw core aspect of your business
and to your point
that's probably what happens with these
with these massive companies is that we
figure out exactly what people need in
the 21st century there's no more fluff
and we move on and we evolve our
business model from there and to your
point a lot is that that probably
doesn't require as many people as before
well here's a basic one that everyone
can understand how many of these
companies are going to try and operate
with less office space less Commerce
office space a ton of them so many of
them maybe all of them and then so if
you have fewer people that are going to
the office on a given day does that
impact jobs heck yes think about all the
people that the building employees to
clean to operate to repair and then all
of the businesses around that office
that serve the workers every day like
the food trucks the umbrella sales
person the shoe shine like whatever the
heck it is all of that goes away because
now you're in your company saying you
know what
like I don't need all this fancy office
space and then what does that do to
commercial rents obviously they'll go
down and plumb it and then you'll look
around saying like well then like what's
going on with this commercial district
like there are all of these cascading
economic effects of these companies
adopting a lighter office foot
footprints right you you and scar
Moochie talk about this you talk about a
pre-vaccine economy in a post vaccine
economy right we're like the pre vaccine
is lightly what we're going through
right now or it's like the social
distancing piece companies are reeling
we're not sure what's happening in our
business now and in the future
and then post vaccine his argument was
after the Spanish flu we had the roaring
20s and the economy just literally roars
back because they like the pent-up
demand let me ask you this is that pent
up demand I'm assuming is not gonna be
anywhere close to enough but how much of
it is how far short is it gonna fall
because you know it's gonna roar back in
some way right like how how short is it
falling even if we see like rapid demand
increase once there's a vaccine we're
gonna put up historic growth numbers
because right now we're coming off such
a low base to me the question is how
does the average American family feel
that resurgence and growth and can they
participate so if you're that unemployed
worker like you know does the resurgence
bring you back with it I think both of
these things are going to be true I
think we're gonna have massive massive
looking growth numbers because again we
just hit like
record declines so if you have even
halfway back someone called it like the
reverse checkmark it's not gonna be a V
it's gonna be like the Vidal and then
like half of the V up and so you can
make an argument that half of a V up is
very dramatic growth which it will be
you know it's like if you go from know
everyone stuck at home to like 70% of
people leave the home then it's gonna
look great but then the gap is still
going to affect millions even tens of
millions of workers that are not going
to be able to participate in the
recovery so both of these things are
going to be true and they're certainly
going to be finance types on CNBC
crowing about how how unprecedented the
growth number is look but more and more
people are going to be left out and
that's really what we have to plan for
and try and accommodate right now is to
try and not miss the millions of workers
who just got kicked out of the workforce
you weren't gonna find a way back in and
in my mind there is no way to do that
that does not involve massive government
intervention like the private market
will not bring all these people back in
they've already the fried market already
failed the people and now we have this
right now that the the hill that climbs
even steeper do you think how's this
affect the election you know guy I
thought like hey if this is gonna all
just go skyrocketing Trump's gonna
mismanaged his way out of this and
doesn't matter for the Democrats running
as long as it's relatively palatable the
most Americans they're gonna want their
restoration of normalcy in government if
the economy's roaring like that Trump
have a shot where's your head at as we
head into November right now I think
that trumps the favor to lose you know
and it almost doesn't matter who's
against him where millions of Americans
have just decided that this is not the
leadership we needed the direction we
want and we're going to make a change I
think it's gonna be a referendum on
Trump I think he loses AI for our sake I
hope you're right
and for conservatives listening this
it's it's less about the candidate and
more about just fixing the country you
know like we've clearly seen what type
of leadership we get now you know
and it's hurting us so anyway Andrew and
Anthony scar Moochie the mooch talked
about the economy talked about the
future of jobs talked about well I love
it looks like I love the mooches
perspective because he's not just a
financier but he's an entrepreneur is an
operator you like you know runs normal
businesses like restaurants is from a
construction family on Long Island like
you know he's not some [ __ ] who's
like sky-high and like you know just
staring down at the economy through a
bunch of screens like he actually
understands the real economy yeah he's
also he's kinda I'm he can be political
but he's bailed to the apolitical like
he was for Obama and Clinton but he was
Mitt Romney's finance director like
that's the spectrum for him he's pretty
down pretty much down the middle which i
think is a helpful perspective on the
economy today where you know that he's
just gonna call it like it is he worked
for something for what ten days
something that I can't remember an
electron like they talk about that a
little bit too so tune in Anthony's car
Moochie joins yang speaks
[Music]
[Applause]
alright guys this podcast is sponsored
by helix sleep which provides mattresses
so if you are so bored by this
conversation we did y'all solid and got
you discount on a bed and what's pretty
awesome about helix frankly is they have
this customized survey to fill out and
quiz to take to figure out what type of
bed you prefer and then they customize
it to you so if you sweat at night if
you move around a lot if you have lower
back discomfort upper back you like
being on angle you like it cool like hot
whatever it is you fill it out it's
pretty quick and they customize mattress
for you it's a phone half coils it's
pretty remarkable and one of the coolest
things I found is they ship it in a box
to you so you can get anywhere for me in
living in New York City it's just this
tiny little thing that I can get shipped
my apartment I can bring it in without
having to get delivery guys and etc I
think I need a helix sleep mattress Zack
as my back hurts from carrying this
podcast I'm gonna need one of those
pillows to cry into after that awarded
the number one best overall mattress of
2019 and 2020 by GQ and wired you go to
helix sleep comm slash yang take their
quiz they'll match you with a customized
mattress get a 10 year warranty and
they're offering up to $200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners at helix sleep comm slash
yang that's helix h e li x sleep comm
slash yang for up to $200 off so Zack
you sweat a lot when you sleep that's
that's not cool that's a little too much
it depends man I mean the eight I had a
while my AC was breaking and then yeah I
would have been helpful to have a
mattress that had a hot sleeper if you
will but we've put in the mat we're
putting that in the add probably well
helix sleep comm slash yang get two
hundred bucks off and they're thrown in
two free pillows if you're in the market
for a mattress helix sleep comm slashing
[Music]
[Applause]
welcoming to yang speaks the founder of
skybridge capital the co-chairman of
salt
Anthony scare Mooji the mooch welcome a
Andrew great to be here I don't have my
math hat on but I want you to envision
me with a math hat on right now okay
singing your praises oh thanks man most
of the listeners can't see you so we can
just pretend it's cool that's good they
can they then they won't see that I live
like Oscar Madison in my my home office
you can see like I'm blown to pieces
here because we haven't been able to
move in a while but but it's good to be
on thanks for including me oh you know
having a stack of books behind you just
makes it seem like you read so don't
worry about it
exactly they're just props Andrew so I
owe you a debt of gratitude Anthony that
you're one of the people that pointed
out the scale of this coronavirus crisis
is impact on the economy and said like
look we're gonna need to go much much
bigger to dig our way out of this and
you compared it to a post-war period
yeah is that right yeah well I
appreciate you bringing it up ivy I
think coincidentally we got on the show
together with Don Lemon I know you're a
contributor over there now and Don
brought me on because I had just done a
piece for cnn.com I had done aid
analysis of the adjusted gross income of
all 50 states on a per capita basis and
then reverse engineered into what the
whole look like and what we needed to do
if we were gonna solve the crisis for
the preponderance of the American people
and at that time they were talking about
a trillion dollar stimulus I said it had
to be three point two trillion and
obviously a big component of it was
ideas that you championed during the
campaign which I think are going to be
you know it's that classic thing you're
the classic entrepreneur where people
look at the idea they say okay that's
crazy and then all of a sudden they
recognize after doing a derivative
analysis of the idea how brilliant it
actually
and so I think you are gonna change a
lot of the ways people think about
economics and you know you probably know
this about me maybe you don't I'm a
lifelong Republican I consider myself a
moderate Republican sort are very
socially progressive but you know more
for pro business ideas and keeping
regulation on point not overly
regulating things and so when you look
at Universal base income of things like
okay well that's incredibly socialistic
but when you really analyze it it's one
of the more capitalistic and it's one of
the more individualistic things that
people could do in a society and it's
it's right in the tradition of the
Western Canon of individualism and if we
can get to society to a point where we
can even out the playing field a little
bit I think good government's should be
in the business of creating or helping
to flat now opportunity you know I'm not
for equal outcomes I can tell from your
writing and your speeches you're not
either but the notion of trying to
create more fairness in terms of the
starting blocks in a society and
creating more equal opportunity or a
flat or playing field and education
flatter playing field to get our life
started boy you've done some very
compelling things so my ATIP my I tipped
my math hat to you I've got my hand on
the bill of a math hat tipping it's you
I I appreciate it
you've really to me done something very
valuable pointing out the scale of the
whole based upon what it's going to do
to people's livelihoods and like you
said I mean we're we're I think 2.8
trillion into this thing now you
projected it needs to be at least three
point two and one I'd love to unpack
with you Anthony is what the heck we're
gonna do to rebuild the economy moving
forward like you worked briefly at the
the White House but so let's say that
you and I are in the White House like at
in a conference room shooting the [ __ ]
like January 2021 and we're faced with
this I was only there for 11 days every
sec
the white house is valuable to me but go
ahead I'm imagining it I mean we might
be able to double your 11 days pretty if
you become president one of my
requirement to help you next time but
one of my honorary requests is you just
have to make me a White House employee
for 12 days okay and I by the way that's
why I could be in the basement serving
food it's okay but just want to try to
get some very reasonable ask I got it
sure sure Boutique so to me we're facing
this giant hole still in the economy and
I'm upset that the vast majority of this
2.8 trillion that's been authorized
seems like it's heading in some
directions not others it seems like
small fractions going straight to the
pocketbooks and wallets of the
struggling American on the street who
literally could be on the street pretty
soon so I was with a an economist
yesterday and he said that 42 percent of
the jobs that have been lost thus far
are not coming back according to their
analysis so if we've lost 30 3.5 million
jobs throughout this crisis and let's
say 40 to 50 percent of them are not
coming back which I see as very very
reasonable maybe even optimistic because
if you look at the types of jobs that
are gone and then you look at the
business climate moving forward if
you're an employer right now are you
going to be hiring are you gonna even
bring people back look are you gonna be
looking to try and scale back your
expenses wait it out but you know I mean
you have to be vital to a business right
now for someone to be like yeah I'm
gonna bring you back or hire you and
many many of these jobs that have been
lost are in industries that are going to
be contracting significantly for a long
time to come I mean brick-and-mortar
retail airlines cruise ships bars
restaurants concert halls convention
centers like you name it like how many
of those businesses are really going to
be back a hundred percent in my mind
virtually none of them so if you're
looking at a whole of let's call it 15
million jobs or so which is about what
like 42 percent of 33 million
so if you're looking at a whole of 15
million jobs and people's way of life
are deteriorating you know in each of
those households because I'm looking
around being like alright I don't have a
job and my old employers not bringing me
back like what is the plan we need like
a Marshall Plan scale initiative to
rebuild country and that's what I wanted
to talk to you about we say feel like
you've got one of the sharpest minds
around these issues business finance
market so the US government stepping
back skybridge economic analysis they've
got 12 point seven trillion dollars
available I like a lot of elements of it
Andrew but the ubi element needs to be
higher you remember from our
conversation I was saying 3,000 an adult
1500 a kid they went with 1200 and 500
it's just not enough money and so what's
gonna happen is it's gonna create a lot
of economic anxiety as we get into the
summer and fall where people are gonna
miss rent payments or they're gonna miss
important needs potential services for
themselves a lot of companies are
looking up and saying wait why am i
paying all this money for these offices
when it turns out that people working
from home is as efficient or more cost
efficient in various ways I mean and
then you think about vacant office space
that impacts a lot of other parts of the
economy obviously I mean if you have you
know like think about all of the the
food trucks the cleaning services like
the power lines lightly all of that
stuff that goes in to keeping that
office up and running like all of those
jobs go out the window I want to return
to a couple things because I'm I'm I
love talking to you about this stuff
because you have like a very very firm
grip on the numbers so let's say that
that we're down let's call it you know
33 million jobs or something like that
then you look up and say wait a minute
roughly half of them can be rehired by
these businesses that are having their
payroll and their costs essentially
guaranteed for a year by the PPP
the funds so if I'm a small business and
I've been a small-business owner so I
remember this so you'd look up and say
okay I can apply for a certain amount of
money well number one first of all I'm
gonna say I'm gonna rehire all of my
people because that gives me more money
like am I going to do it we'll see
whatever who knows but right now I'm in
survival mode so if I can get ahold of
some cash I'll do it
and then when it comes time to rehire
people certainly you know if it makes
sense by the numbers or you know it's
like it's easier for me to rehire
someone and let's say I don't need a
hundred percent of my old workers again
let's say I only need 80 like it sounds
like I might rehire that last 20 just
because well they're being paid for and
I don't want to defraud the government
or you know or whatever the issue is so
I'm just going to rehire them but then
let's say the demand at my business is
actually lower and then as soon as this
year elapses I'm going to right-size it
like like my employees are actually paid
for for the year but as soon as that
year is up I'm gonna look around and say
hey that 20% needs to go to me that's
going to be a very reasonable situation
that many businesses will find
themselves in because they're working in
a space that is not going to go back to
full demand because of what you
described as residual permanence so am I
right in saying that a lot of the that
17 million a lot of those 17 million
jobs that are going to be preserved by
PPE that we might see like a second
tranche of job loss when those those PPP
funds no longer apply approximately a
year from now well I mean yes of course
you know you'd have to take a
permutation allowed come analysis and
you'd have to say that what you're
saying is a very large percentage I mean
I've made most of my money if not all of
my money Andrew on statistical outcomes
and betting certain statistical outcomes
pursuant to US markets and global
capital markets and so as a someone that
studied the economy for 31 years
as a you know trained macro economist
you'd have to say that there's a
percentage of what you're saying could
happen the flipside is something similar
could happen what was happening in the
2008 financial crisis and what was that
is that you had this sort of silly putty
activity where the growth wasn't typical
to a normal cyclical recovery
remember in normal cyclical recoveries
measured over 120 years you would get a
six to seven percent bump in GDP go back
to the Reagan years go back to when the
economy recovered after Bill Clinton
took office after the tax program went
in in 93 but the economy sort of silly
putty doubt stretched out one to two
percent growth over 11 years now picked
up a little bit when President Trump cut
taxes and he got a little bit of a sugar
bump in the economy for 17 to 18 and 19
but it's really been a 2 ish percent
growth number and so why is that well
that's because you've got massive and I
mean massive governmental stimulus and
so the great irony to my friends on the
right who are quote unquote free
marketeers and don't like governmental
intervention all this other stuff let's
deal with the world the way it actually
is and not the way they want to pretend
it is and let's look at it for exactly
what's going on we have had government
sizable government intervention in our
equity capital markets and in our
economy since 2008 we've just injected
another sizable dose of that here in
2020 and so what will happen in my
opinion is yes there will be some people
that the PPP's over they'll get fired
but I'm willing to bet and this is why I
think you have foretold the future in
many ways that there'll be other landing
spaces for these people to drop into
over time and I think that the big
problem that we have when we're thinking
about the world is that we're trained
biologically to think linearly and so we
say ok this is what happened and so this
is what's likely gonna happen
in a linear movement and I can give you
global historical examples of that so
Thomas Malthus for your listeners he was
a British economist in the 1830s he said
man we got a serious problem on our
hands where we're gonna starve our
population is growing exponentially we
can only produce the food in a linear
sort of way and so we're gonna end up
starving and that was a Malthusian
proposition and he got it wrong because
he wasn't thinking exponentially about
the society wasn't thinking about all
the growth the innovation the irrigation
the genetically modified foods and lo
and behold two hundred and fifty years
after his demise we have more people
that are affected by obesity they're
dying from obesity-related illnesses
than they are from starvation you and I
are I'm older than you but I can take
you back to the 1980s where a economic
professor of mine said Peak Oil Theory
we're running out of oil by 2015
there'll be no oil 30 years from now
prepare for the worst and and we didn't
have that happen because we had all this
exponential innovation that took place
fracking satellite technology it was
able to look for oil in places we didn't
even know it existed and you know come
on we had oil in a negative cotangent
last month where it was minus 37 dollars
a barrel and so so what I'm cautioning
people of yes your analysis in a linear
perspective is correct but then you're
not factoring in more ponderous
governmental intervention you're not
factoring in changes to tax policy that
will incentivize these people I do
predict again I'm a small restaurant
owner minority owner in a restaurant I
do predict that they're gonna pass a
hundred percent deductibility on
business lunches that will come in the
next wave of legislation because it is a
surefire way to engage those restaurants
100 percent people tax-deductible
business lunches this is the first I
have heard of this I can't believe that
the government is going to pay us to eat
out
well they did it they did it up until
the 1987 tax reform and and they they
abolished it in 1987 and they brought it
down to like 50% now it was it went from
100% 225 to 250 but I think it's going
back up I think they're gonna allow you
to write that off on your business
because they're gonna want to stimulate
talk about people that have really been
hammered Andrew think of that bartender
that waitress the cleaning staff I mean
they have been hammered and you know if
you talk to Tommy Colicchio or some of
the big celebrity chefs they're like man
they make these restaurants they're
gonna need something that's a way for
the government to stimulate business
activity so all I'm saying is don't
think about this linearly because
exponential things are going to happen
that are gonna seismically change the
way things go on because you're an
entrepreneur I'm an entrepreneur we know
how to do more with less we're both have
Swiss Army knives in our mind you know
I'm blown from the White House you know
typical guy probably wouldn't have taken
it the way I took it I mean I got a
pretty tough skin I just flipped to
another you know device or tool in my
Swiss Army and I've go back to work
point being is there's good there's a
lot of resiliency out there that people
are under estimating well certainly by
the time your elapses things may be
different and that's what I'd love to
pick your brain about is that if you
were to say look here are a couple of
the measures or three or four of the
measures that you think that we need to
adopt so that we help create more
opportunities for that bartender that a
cleaning person the nail salon owner
like what does that look like because
for me to me it's got to be jobs out
jobs I mean if you've wiped out tens of
millions of jobs we need to get money
into people's hands because you know
there's no time to wait and I said it
seems like you agree with me on that
totally I think I think you are one of
the nation's leading economic thinkers
on that issue and your presidential
campaign forced me
intellectually to really study what your
proposals were and I mean I confess this
to you and I confess this to the yang
gang and don't be mad at me but when I
first heard it I was like okay that's
ridiculous that's gonna create a ton of
lazy people and Nan invested people in
the society and so that was my first
reaction and then I said okay let me
look at this thing this guy's a very
compelling guy he's very articulate I
need to understand where he's coming
from and then I started to peel the
economic layers off of what you were
saying intellectually and I am right
where you are I may even be worse than
you at this point in terms of the level
that needs to be distributed if you
really want to create more fairness in
the society and calm down the Ignatian
of people related to the wealth gap and
so so you know you're what you're saying
and what I totally agree with and I try
to reference in that stimulus editorial
that I wrote is you're gonna need a
little bit more money you can leave a
little bit more assistance if you took
the numbers that the government's
talking about and you divided it by the
per capita it's about seven thousand
dollars a person for the stimulus yeah
if you just handed it to the people
would that be a more efficient way of
doing it than the way they're doing it
right now and the answer is obviously
yes but you know our legislation
legislative process is a sausage factory
and there's people in there with their
fists and a grab bag and you know from
history when we had the war in World War
two the claim to fame that raised Harry
Truman's profile was that he started a
commission in the Senate to analyze
fraud from all the war munitions and all
the war contracting that was going on
where people were in there stealing from
the government and and so that's gonna
happen again I mean it's unavoidable but
yes more you bi a lot more jobs training
we need a 25 year plan to rethink our K
through 12 public educational system we
need to right-size it and make it fairer
if I grow up in Scarsdale or here in
Manhasset New York I've got the luck of
the draw where I'm gonna have a very
good public school system but I'm I grew
up in a certain area that's kind of Lisa
rice says you tell me the zip code of
the child I can tell you whether or not
they can get a good public education or
not then the society is Rich's ORS we
need a better intellectual policy
discussion about that less centered on
unions less centered on self-interest
less centered on businesspeople or
unions for that matter am i picking on
any one group it has to be right or
wrong injured what I enjoyed about your
campaign once I started studying it is
you're really focused on right or wrong
policy you're not really focused on left
or right policy I mean I'd be interested
to ask you a question why are you a
Democrat how did you become a Democrat I
can tell you why I'm a Republican even
though I don't even fit in the
Republican Party anymore I'm a
Republican because the union's my dad
was in a union here on Long Island 41
years as a blue-collar crane operator
hourly worker and anybody that's lived
out here in Nassau County knows that the
unions were controlled by the Republican
Party so when I was a kid growing up my
dad was a staunch Republican for those
reasons and he was like you know what
you're a Republican and oh by the way
you're turning 18 yeah that's great
you're registering as a Republican I
said okay if that's helpful to you dad
then that's what I'm gonna be that's how
I became a Republican how did you become
a Democrat well certainly not anything
like what you just described you as my
parents weren't political at all my
parents immigrated here and pretty much
ignored domestic politics for me no I
remember being excited about Clinton's
election in 92 and I aligned with
Democrats on social issues around choice
and other things and so it just became
very natural and of course like you mean
I grew up in the New York area at least
my part of New York I felt like was
democratic-leaning but you're you
represent a type of business owner
mentality that I also really embrace and
resemble because I've run a
a small private company and when you're
in that context it's all just about the
facts it's like you can't talk yourself
in anything you know I think you know if
you decide to run again I don't know
what your long-term plans are but
there's a wave coming and it will be a
post-partisan wave it'll be an
exhaustion of this North going Zack
South going Zack smashing into each
other arguing it out on cable news
lots of nonsensical policy to something
that is more advanced than that
something that's more data-driven and
something that's more thoughtful that
will reengineer aspects of the society
that are in shalini dove a refreshening
and so if you decide to run again there
is a window in my opinion and there's a
line to go through of a post-partisan
you'll have to pick one of the two
parties Democrat or Republican because
the way they've locked this thing up
it's a full-blown duopoly but you can
take that lane and and if you're
thinking about it in multiple decade
periods of time which I know you are you
can really improve a lot of the things
that are going on in America and I hope
that happens
[Music]
right now today huge tech companies in
America that are paying next to nothing
in taxes are sucking up our data every
single day they are taking your web
history your email metadata your video
searches and they create a detailed
profile on you and then they cut it up
into little pieces and then sell it
resell it and we're none the wiser we
don't get a dime they're not just
selling their products anymore they're
selling us they're selling our data we
have become this product in this matrix
like his system where they're just
taking our info and making money off of
it so what can we do about it well we're
working on a few things to help but one
thing you can do is you can use Express
VPN every time you go online now what
the heck is expressvpn VPN stands for
virtual private network and if you think
about all the websites you visit every
single day using your public IP address
they can match up your activity to your
IP address and that's how they know what
you're doing so if you want to be more
anonymous online and make it so that
you're more protected and they don't
know everything you're doing then you
can sign up on expressvpn it's pretty
easy to use I downloaded this it took me
30 seconds it was the easiest thing in
the world my internet runs just as fast
so I'm a fan I've always been a fan of
VPNs our entire staff was very big on
them during the campaign because of data
privacy concerns so if this sounds like
something you'd be into visit expressvpn
dot-com slash yang to get three months
for free on a one-year package that's
exp our e SS VPN dot-com slash yang
that's expressvpn dot-com slash yang
you'll be a little bit safer a little
bit more secure a little bit more
anonymous and the tech companies will be
left a little bit poorer as a result not
that I'm out to impoverish tech
companies but you know what I mean
[Music]
beyond the things that you and I have
just talked about like what are the
things where you're like look the here's
where we should try and lead the country
in terms of like big policy proposal
where we should be allocating some of
these hundreds of billions of dollars I
would say what you said jobs jobs jobs
whatever makes that happen but I really
believe we have to have a transformative
infrastructure policy we could do it off
balance sheet - you could go to the
fortune 500 and you can say okay listen
Apple you've got 150 170 billion in cash
drop 50 billion of that into an
infrastructure bank and go to each of
our nation's greatest businesses that
are sitting on cash piles give them a
tax incentive to drop it into an
infrastructure bank and then we could go
out through the private sector lever
that infrastructure bank you know and
you could have a three or four trillion
dollar infrastructure program that is
actually backed by the public sector you
know the primary size that's incredible
and that was an idea that I had and we
tried to get it into the tax reform bill
but you know you've got special
interests and you know listen I mean you
know you know this from politics the
Democrats you know they love the idea
but they're not going to implement the
idea because I don't want to make Trump
look good you know is that sort of thing
but I just want you to imagine it'll
make just imagine us going to companies
and saying listen we'll give you a ten
year tax abatement you can repatriate
your capital back into the United States
but you got to give it to us for ten
years and you know I've studied
infrastructure and so just quickly for
your listeners the big dig in Boston
when I left Boston when I came out of
Harvard Law School in 1989 they were
starting the Big Dig they said it would
cost two billion dollars and it would be
done by 1994 it costs 22 billion bucks
and it was done by 2002 and so the cost
overruns were astronomical the graft was
astronomical the
RUP shin was astronomical well let me
tell you something okay that twenty-two
billion dollars was incredibly well
spent because sixteen new suburbs grew
up in the metropolitan area around
Boston it improved the technological hub
of i-95 immeasurably the tax revenues
went up the the prices on people's homes
went up it had an unbelievable
multiplier effect in terms of the
economic rent it deployed again not to
overly walk out on you but go back to
the moon landing twenty five billion
dollars of nineteen sixty nine dollars
which is approximately four hundred
billion dollars today John Kennedy nine
years land somebody on the moon the
positive externalities GPS not you
picked up tang and aluminum foil and
post-it notes he got those but you also
innovated the internet innovated global
telecommunications created GPS I mean
you you had according to Douglas
Brinkley the American historian in his
book last year he calculated one point
four trillion dollars of positive
externalities from the technological
innovation required by our nation to put
somebody on the moon seeped into the
private sector of our economy so I'm
sitting with you know infrastructure
will pay for itself in in any number of
ways with you hopefully you're the
president and I would tell you
infrastructure infrastructure
infrastructure let's go do this because
if you really want a lasting legacy for
your young children and my young
children we need to come up with a
creative financial way to re-energize
the infrastructure
to me this was shocking that Trump
didn't at least build a ton of stuff
just to put his name on it I thought
this would be a slam-dunk for him I
think he wanted to actually you know you
know I think he wanted to he was just
getting blocked left right and center
and you may remember this day one they
wanted him to go for health care reform
he wanted to go for tax they wanted to
go for health care reform I had a
conversation with him in late December
when they were coming up with this and
he said so what do you think we should
do and I said well if I were you I would
go for a very small bipartisan win I I
thought you could get an education
reform bill together that both parties
would be forced to go alongside of and I
said I would go with the infrastructure
stuff because you can get both parties
in there it's traditionally bipartisan I
mean you know now you're mark you're the
marketing czar you're repositioning
yourself as somebody that's not in the
partisan rancor and you're not in that
fight but they convinced him to go with
Medicare and I'm sorry you know I'm
sorry not Medicare healthcare and here's
what I would say to you is you know it's
a true statement and people would be
pissed off for me for saying it but I'll
say it anyway his lack of political
experience caused him to overly trust
people that were politicians and so they
were fighting their usual tribal battles
and usual tribal fights so they were
going after each other smashing each
other and if he had stepped above the
fray and done something bipartisan you
know he could have been the person that
was transformational and sort of led
them out of the ridiculousness and the
polemics that were exercising right now
but anyway that didn't happen and here
we are and I got my ass blown out of the
White House after 11 days so what do I
know but before we go I just want to
personally applaud you because I thought
as a very bold initiative to run for
president you brought ideas to the table
that were fresh and innovative and I
think you have a very very important
voice in the American business political
and sort of cultural zeitgeist so I'm a
big fan of yours Andrew and I really big
honor for me to be on your podcast and I
I want to stay in touch I hope that I'm
looking forward to watching your future
unfold I know it's gonna be a very
bright one for you thank you and you
know we're gonna be we're gonna be very
busy you know we have a lot of work to
do you and I and I would love to work
with you on this and many other things
because this is
great project of our age I love your
time horizons - you're like we're gonna
be out this for 25 years no one thinks
that long term anymore I mean I'm just
telling you I say well the Chinese do
Andrew you know that the Chinese
Communist Party is a plan 20:49 they
started that plan about 10 years ago and
where they want to be metrically for
their economy and their people by 20 49
and so us we used to have long term
thinking the Marshall Plan was a long
term thought the moon landing was long
term thought the strategy of containment
to end the repression of communism
soviet-style communism was a long term
thought but today our politicians think
in like two minutes
soundbites fighting it out on cable TV
we need to get back to that longer-term
thinking which is sorely needed to
refresh the society America 2.0 Anthony
that's we're gonna Chris today I'm going
to say it's America team window in the
21st century well thank you all the best
of the family stay safe stay healthy and
yeah like I appreciate the heck out of
your time god bless all right and you be
well
[Music]